ايه
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[Arabic recitation]
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
اشهد ان لا
اله الا الله
[Silence]
اشهد ان
اله
الا
الله
اشهد ان محمدا
رسول الله
[Silence]
اشهد ان
محمدا
رسول
الله
[Silence]
حي على صلاه
حي على
[Silence]
حي على الفلاح ا
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
ইলাহা
ইল্লাল্লাহ
الله
[Silence]
ان الحمد لله
نحمده ونستعينه ونستغفره
ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا وسيئات
اعمالنا
من يهده الله فلا مضل ظل له
ومن يضلل فلا هادي له
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق تقاته
ولا تموتن الا وانتم مسلمون
يا ايها الناس
اتقوا ربكم الذي خلقكم من نفس واحده
وخلق منها زوجها
وبث منهما رجالا كثيرا ونساء
واتقوا الله الذي تساءلون به والارحام
ان كان عليكم رقيبا
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله
اتقوا الله وقولوا قولا سديدا
يصلح لكم اعمالكم
ويغفر لكم ذنوبكم
ومن يطع الله ورسوله فقد فاز فوزا عظيما
اما بعد فان اصدق الحديث كتاب الله
وخير الهدي هدي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
وشر الامور محدثاتها
وكل محدثه بدعه
وكل بدعه ضلاله
وكل ضلاله في النار
اما بعد
فيقول الله تعالى
في كتابه الكريم
فهل ينظرون الا ان تاتيهم الساعه بغته
فقد جاء اشراطها
الله سبحانه وتعالى
سوره القتال
سوره محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
سبحانه وتعالى
alles
allر
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
and you not
for
youen
‏arev
you have you haveid
irable
and youitate
yourover
الله
[Silence]
وى
صلى الله عليه
‏notify
worship الله
being
life can always do better
why don't we do better why what is
keeping you back الله سبحانه وتالى says
to you he say to me he say to all of
‏before
take
فقد جاء اشراطها
[Silence]
‏signs of the last day
the signs of the hour
tells us in the prophet time
صلى الله عليه وسلم فقد جاء اشراطها
‏you have no more time because even
the ball roll
beg
appro upon
‏by whispers ofem
and
whersemassal
and those form is you have more
timeation
انء الله
الشيطان
[Silence]
and الله سبحانه وى
‏first
day of judg
and
days
of propid
and second ofg
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله سبحانه وتعالى
‏You have right now there no more time
whats
people
fromading the of and between them andv
‏di
peopleell
findell
ination
allanously
askom
if you take us out ofell if ‏You give us
just a little more time, just one more
day, just one more hour, just one more
chance do better.
That is what they grown with day and
night in the depths of hell.
‏Most people don't go to the hell fire
because they are unaware of the truth
because they don't know genin confused.
People go to the hell fire only because
they have chosen to go there.
‏chobedience
with ination
الله سبحانه وتالى
انهم يرونه بعيدا ونراه قريبا
سبحانه وتعالى
‏ant
andomingending
more time
things
صلى الله عليه وسلم
صحيح الامام البخاري
انس بن مالك لا ياتي على الناس زمان الا
والذي بعده شر منه
صلى الله عليه
‏is more difficult to be good in
increasingly bad
in increasingly godless world a that
scofs at religion a world that scofs at
the notion of a creator.
‏and
only by their
genitals.
‏cap
any
الامام النسائي
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ان من ورائكم ايام الصبر
الصبر فيهن مثل قبض على الجمر
للمتمسك فيهن بمثل ما انتم عليه اليوم اجر
50 رجلا منكم
قالوا يا رسول الله منا ام منهم قال بل
منكم
سنن النسائي صلى الله عليه
‏said what is your generation
are the days of pa
those days is more agoningy
to hold on lit
on l in your
‏said those holdist
for those who hold to what you all are
those days
of 50
of us 50 of them said 50 of
‏Now this doesn't mean that we have a
chance of being moreous than the
companion
but what this me is that in one as
the people who come later have a much
more difficult path
those days of the companions
in one sense
the companions they went through the
most difficult of trials
‏was
not so much
and soon the prop
said for those l
of men and wom brothers and sisters who
study and hold
‏that which you all are upon today
speaking to companion
the reward of 50 among you
because they traverse a land
with mind
prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
anotherم
مسلم
عبد الرحمن ابن عبد رب الكعبه
مكه
عبد الله بن عمرو بن العاص رضي الله عنهما
صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
عبد الله بن عمر بن العاص
كنا مع رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم في
سفر
فنزلنا منزلا
فمنا من ينتظ
ومنا من هو في جشره
يعني مع غنماته ومنا من يصلح خباءه
اذ سمعنا منادي رسول الله صلى صلى الله
عليه وسلم يقول الصلاه قائمه فاجتمعنا الى
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم فقال
انه لم يكن نبي قبلي الا كان حقا عليه ان
يدل امته على خير ما يعلمه لهم وان ينذرهم
شر ما يعلمه لهم
وان امتكم هذه قد جعل عافيتها في اولها
وسيصيب اخرها بلاء وامور تنكرونها
وتجيء فتنه يرقق بعضها بعضا وتجيء الفتنه
فيقول المؤمن هذه مهلكتي ثم تنكشف
وتجيء الفتنه فيقول المؤمن هذه هذه فمن
احب ان يزحزح عن النار ويدخل الجنه فلتاته
منيته
وهو يؤمن بالله واليوم الاخر ولياتي الى
الناس الذي يحب ان يؤتى اليه
ومن بايع اماما فاعطاه صفقه يده وثمره
قلبه فليطعه ان استطاع
فان جاء اخر ينازعه فاضربوا عنق الاخر
عبد الله بن عمرو بن العاص رضي الله عنهما
الله صلى الله عليه
‏And we st along the way to up for the
evening and people dispersed as they do.
There were those of us who were tending
to his livestock.
‏There those who fixing and setting up
their for the and those who pry
when we
call announcing الصلاه قائمه
now the prophet
when he wish to call the companions to
قد قامت الصلاه
مؤذن
قائمه
صلى الله عليه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
before
it was
upon him
inform his nation and followers of the
best that
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتالى
الله
تابعين تابع التابعين
‏L generations
said na
spared earliest generation
and later generations will be afflict
with fit and chos
[Silence]
‏ion
quantify
what
صلى الله عليه
‏tribulations
and trials and tribulations are not in
people's physical
b it's not that people during those days
will be physically uncomfortable that
most of us will have nothing to wear or
nothing to eat that is what our
companions went through to bring us this
religion we are too comfortable
‏areableit
was about no have bell
have
our will never toot toold without ourion
theit of the later generit
myit
‏willigion
the prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
and said and trials and tribulations
they will come in waves.
Each wave will dwarf the previous.
‏Listen listen to the way he said that
each wave ofit
will
the prev wave meaning time wave ofit
comes upon us will make
child
will make wish for the fit ofesterday
because again as we at the begin of خطبه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
notysical
ourion our
‏and more
willing
those daysy
and prop
said those trials and tribulations will
come in waves
each wave will the prev
and during those
‏willaking
said a wave of will come and will
this is
my unding there no way
enough to get through this and will just
asever isushing
‏prop صلى الله عليه
‏said so wishes to be removed from the
hell fire and admitted into parad
his death is to subd him while he is in
a state of belief in Allah in the last
day
and he brings unto others what he wishes
اقول ما تسمعون واستغفر الله لي ولكم
ولسائر المسلمين فاستغفروه انه هو الغفور
الرحيم
الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم
وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين اما بعد
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
ابو هريره
بخاري مسلم
صلى الله عليه وسلم
بادروا بالاعمال فتنا كقطع الليل المظلم
يصبح الرجل فيها مؤمنا ويمسي كافرا او
يمسي مؤمنا ويصبح كافرا يبيع
دينه بعرض من الدنيا
صلى الله عليه وسلم
account
with
you drawing your days of weakness to get
you by and to get you ‏those days of
darkness he said
to do good deeds before tribulations
manifest among humanity
these tribulations are more dark pieces
of a dark night at night
during these days of tribulations a man
will be a believer in the morning only
to disbelieve by evening
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتعالى بمنه وكرمه وجوده
سبحانه وتعالى
الله سبحانه وتعالى
‏are
us of
the courage ofing to spite of thequing
for and upon and nobility of being
اللهمنا
وكفر عنا سيئات نا وتوفنا مع الابرار ربنا
واتنا ما وعدتنا على رسلك ولا تخزنا يوم
القيامه انك لا تخلف الميعاد اللهم اننا
نسالك فعل الخيرات وترك المنكرات وحب
المساكين وان تغفر لنا وترحمنا وتتوب
علينا واذا اردت بعبادك فتنه فاقبضنا اليك
غير مفتونين اللهم ربنا اننا نعوذ بك من
الغلا والربا والزنا والزلازل والمحن
والفتن ما ظهر منها وما بطن اللهم اقسم
لنا من خشيتك ما تحول به بيننا وبين
معصيتك ومن طاعتك ما تبلغنا به جنتك ومن
اليقين ما تهون به علينا مصائب الدنيا
ومتعنا اللهم باسماعنا
وابصارنا
وقواتنا ما احييتنا واجعله الوارث منا
واجعل ثارنا على من ظلمنا وانصرنا على من
عادانا اللهم انصر الاسلام والمسلمين
واخذل الشرك والمشركين وافضح النفاق
والمنافقين
اللهم انصر اخواننا المجاهدين المضطه في
كل مكان اللهم انصرهم على عدوهم واجعلهم
على عدوهم ظاهرين قاهرين منصورين يا رب
العالمين اللهم عليك بعدوك وعدوهم فانهم
لا يعجزونك اللهم زلزل اركانهم وصدع
بنيانهم واقتل اجنادهم واجعل قتلاهم في
النيران واجعل احيائهم في ذل وهوان اللهم
امين وصل اللهم وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب
العالمين
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله اشهد ان لا اله
الا الله
اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله اشهد اشهد ان
محمدا
رسول الله
حي على الصلاه حي على الصلاه حي على
الفلاح حي على الفلاح
قد قامت الصلاه قد قامت الصلاه الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا اله الا الله
استووادوا
صلى الله عليه ‏Pleas
are your feeters andetors
الله اكبر سبحانك اللهم وبحمدك وتبارك
[Arabic recitation]
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
القارعه
ما القارعه
وما
ادراكما القارعه
يوم يكون الناس كالفراش المبثوث
وتكون الجبال كال العهن المنفوش
فاما من ثقلت موازينه
فهو في عيشه راضيه
واما من خفت موازينه
فامه
هاويه
وما
ادراكما هي نار حاميه
[Arabic recitation]
كثيرا طيبا
[Silence]
الله اكبر بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله
الهاكم التكاثر
الهاكم التكاثر حتى زرتم المقابر
كلا سوف تعلمون
ثم كلا سوف تعلمون
كلا لو تعلمون علم اليقين
لترون
الجحيم
ثم لترونها
عين اليقين
ثم لتسالن
يومئذ عن النعيم
الله
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله.
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
সিস্টার আসসালামু আলাইকুম
ফস্ট ওয়ান্ট টু থ্যাংক
ইমাম আলী লাফ
இஷஹஸ்
ஆ
எட
கஷோஹங்ஹ
আগ
হাকা
সফ
অন
সারড
পজফট
প্রেন্স
পসড অনবসাইট
এন্ডংফর
ফিডব্যাক
இম আটিশল্লাহ
[Silence]
ইনশল্লাহ
‏pleas donate